según el estatuto de roma adoptado en
1998 por 123 países los crímenes de
guerra son aquellos que violan el
convenio de ginebra en 1949 y entre los
que están el homicidio intencional el
hecho de causar deliberadamente grandes
sufrimientos o de atentar gravemente
contra la integridad física y la salud o
el dirigir intencionalmente ataques
contra la población civil quien tiene la
potestad de investigar estos crímenes de
guerra es la corte penal internacional
entró en funcionamiento en 2003 y que
busca que los responsables rindan
cuentas de sus crímenes y evitar que
vuelvan a ocurrir entre los países que
están siendo investigados por la corte
penal internacional están venezuela
costa de marfil malí libia sudán
república centroafricana república
democrática del congo uganda kenia
georgia afganistán mianmar filipinas y
ucrania la investigación de este último
país inició el 2 de marzo sólo una
semana después de que iniciara la guerra
rusa pero aprovecharán para investigar
delitos cometidos desde 2003 en la
península ucraniana de crimea en el este
del país a pesar de que la corte penal
puede investigar crímenes de guerra y de
lesa humanidad las potencias mundiales
como estados unidos rusia china o india
no la reconocen y han firmado el
estatuto de roma las decisiones de este
organismo no los cobijar y han aunque
posiblemente crearían la presión
internacional necesaria para detener
estos delitos